des gens meurent littéralement de shows
en inde et au pakistan voici ce qu'il se
passe depuis plusieurs semaines les deux
pays font face à des températures
extrêmes pouvant atteindre par endroit
les 50 degrés en plus de cette chaleur
le taux d'humidité est lui aussi très
élevé ces conditions sont considérés
comme invivable car le corps humain ne
parvient plus à se réguler par la
transpiration un humain peut survivre à
une très forte chaleur sèche mais quand
l'humidité devient également trop
importantes comme c'est le cas en inde
et au pakistan cela devient
insupportable même un jeune adulte en
bonne santé ne peut alors pas rester
plus de quelques heures à l'extérieur
vingt-cinq personnes sont déjà mortes à
cause de la chaleur dans l'état indien
du maharashtra
depuis mars le faute explique que la
mortalité liée aux canicules en inde a
augmenté de plus de 60% depuis 1980
d'après le ministre indien des sciences
de la terre selon le dernier rapport du
giec les vagues de chaleur sont l'une
des conséquences les plus visibles du
changement climatique l' oms estime qu
entre 2030 et 2050 le changement
climatique entraînera près de 250 mille
décès supplémentaires par an dans le
monde